alright now this process here that we
just went through see all this you can
do this every time you can take have a
look at all these triangles none of them
are right angled but you can always find
some right angled triangles in there so
being you can do this all the time every
time no matter what triangle you've got
therefore we sort of define this as a
rule because it always works that's why
we have rules okay so what I'd like you
to do is I want you to redraw this
triangle but with no numbers or letters
on it just redraw the diagram with this
perpendicular height just don't label
anything say it again if you pay
attention I'll show it to you
okay so here's what we're doing to try
and do right see this guy over here this
guy is not this particular triangle it's
any triangle right so I asked you not to
put any labels on you can put these
labels on because these are so
nondescript a and B and C could be
anything
do you notice I've distinguished between
capitals and lowercase right the
Capitals are the points for the angles
and the lowercase ones are the lengths
does that make sense
mister sir hey guys are you looking for
someone
Sheikh is just over here anyone else
jacob' is pretty special that's okay
thanks thank you okay now here's what
we're gonna do we're going to rehearse
this but we're gonna rehearse it with
algebra which is a bit trickier than
with numbers but we just did it so it
shouldn't be too hard
let's look at the left-hand triangle
okay that's where we started in this
triangle I'm gonna look at this angle
over here what would you call that
it's just angle a right so sine of that
angle is gonna be one on what opposite
in this triangle here right opposite on
hypotenuse do you agree in my triangle
opposite on hypotenuse is that okay what
did i do at this point over here what'd
I do
oh yeah okay I'm gonna get to that in a
second before I get to the next triangle
though I wanted to get H on its own
because I'm gonna cancel it later so H
is B sine a is that okay now I'm gonna
take out on suggestion and look at the
other triangle what's the angle I'm
interested in its its capital B right
what's it equal to
opposite on hypotenuse that okay just
like sine usually is so just like before
I can multiply to get rid of the
denominator okay now where did I go at
this point I said hey look you're
looking at the same object dude like
you're both talking about H same team so
therefore these things should be this
thing and this thing should be equal
because they're both H so therefore I
have this now this is nice it's got kind
of a ring to it B sine a equals a sine B
but I can write it even nicer than that
I'm gonna divide both sides by a be
watch this
a B a B okay because it's they're just
numbers so I can divide both sides what
cancels on the left-hand side yeah
correct
so I've got the capital A's which are
the angles well the capital letters are
the angles and then I've got the little
letters which are the links that okay so
yes they absolutely are you might think
it's a bit weird why do I am I've got
like a million one nine million I've got
plenty of other letters I can choose
from why don't we use these ones I will
tell you why in a second okay to answer
that question what cancels on the left
the B's damn man what about on the right
it's the A's okay we're doing can you
rewrite the next line without any
canceling stuff what do you get
okay now mathematicians were always
looking for nice neat beautiful ways to
say things okay and I think even though
we usually don't like fractions I think
this is better than the line we started
with because look all of the A's are on
one side all of the B's are on one side
so what does this mean
you don't need to do this because your
diagram is fine the way it is
but have a look remember I told you
right at the beginning of this topic the
trigonometry is about position right
it's about position where is big a in
relation to little a how are those
things connected to each other they are
opposite right there is the opposite
angle makes sense what about little B
and capital B opposite again that's why
we actually use the same letters we
recycle them so that you get little B is
not just some random thing it's
connected to capital B it's directly
opposite if I redrew this diagram I
could show that I can do it with this
angle sorry this side and this angle as
well so I could say this and they're all
equal which is really nice and beautiful
no more right-angled triangles okay no
more right angle triangles any triangle
at all this will be true okay
you can also turn everything upside down
if you want you get this
[Music]
okay now a rib was very rightly asking
for a quicker way to do this problem
okay now that we've established this
just by the way has a name because it's
full of ARB signs it's called the sign
rule
okay now that we've proved this I can
use it whenever I like so let's have a
go at Part B if we know the formula we
can use it straight away okay now if
you've got two colors if you've got two
colors like I did here it's super useful
because watch what I'm looking for are
angles and sides that are opposite each
other okay
so see this B that's the one I want what
angle is opposite B 123
it's a little bit more hard to see but
you can still see it I've got another
length six what angle is opposite that
you see you get this criss-crossing
thing here right
so therefore I can say let's see here
being on sign 123 this is me using the
formula I guess I'm using it like this
down the bottom equals six on sine 25 I
can go straight there no constructions
necessary
so this is what the same rule is telling
me can you go ahead can you give me one
decimal place on what B is supposed to
be six sign 123 degrees divided by sine
of 25 degrees has anyone got it 11 quick
do a sense check does it look reasonable
why is B so big it's almost double what
this one is
why is it so much bigger because the
angle that created it is big 123 degrees
big angle creates a big side exactly
bigger angle means a bigger aside